I have 422 friends, yet I am lonely.
I speak to all of them every day, yet none of them really know me.
The problem I have sits in the spaces between.
Looking into their eyes or at a name on a screen.
I took a step back and opened my eyes.
I looked around and realized this media we call social is anything but.
When we open our computers and it's our doors we shut.
All this technology we have, it's just an illusion.
Community, companionship, a sense of inclusion.
Yet when you step away from this device of delusion.
You awaken to see a world of confusion.
So don't give in to a life where you follow the hype.
Give people your love, don't give them your 'like'.
Disconnect from the need to be heard and defined.
Go out into the world, leave distractions behind.
Look up from your phone.
Shut down that display.
Stop watching this video.
Live life the real way.